hey it's Kennedy for reason TV at CPAC
2014 talking to people about the limits
of federalism in regards to social
issues we used to call it Frederick
Frederick so Freddie so yeah it would be
do you think fred rule isms should
extend to marijuana rights and same-sex
marriage four states should they decide
yeah I think pretty much do you think
that men should marry men and women
should marry women if they so choose no
should the state's decide or should
there be a federal mandate states should
decide that and same with marijuana laws
whether it's legalization or
decriminalization should stay to the
side our state's said you decide and
what about same-sex marriage should the
states be allowed to decide who gets
married again I think that's a state to
supply state decision should states
decide whether or not same-sex marriage
is legal yes should states decide
whether or not medical marijuana is
legal yes we ought to have the diversity
of that the state's give us the
laboratories that they provide for us
let's see what works out I'd like to see
how that situation works out in Colorado
for example so how far does federalism
extend what about medical marijuana or
decriminalizing our legalizing marijuana
should that be left up to the state I
think that that's the right position and
if you see what Governor Perry said an
even governor hickenlooper whose state
has voted to legalize marijuana he
opposed it but he is saying hey the
states you can watch what we're doing
and see how it works out for us and see
how things get implemented and that's
what Governor Perry has backed is
letting the states I'll do it themselves
is Obama bad on federalism
Obamacare if nothing else has proven to
us reminded us once again how difficult
it is and how inappropriate it is for
the federal government to take on these
massive you know enterprises obviously
everything he does has the word national
attached to it but in fairness to him
that has been about the trend in every
presidency since Reagan remember used to
be called these United States as opposed
to the United States historically I used
to be in state government and I can tell
you that decisions on a perfect are
certainly so much better made on the
state level what works for example in
New York doesn't necessarily work in
Wyoming so certainly it makes a lot more
sense do you think conservatives are
using more federalist approach to social
issues they should be yeah yeah while I
may not agree with what a particular
state does on a particular issue for the
most part unless it really does violate
fundamental constitutional principles
they have a right to do what they see
fit and every solution doesn't have to
be a federal one and i think i'm gonna
say across the board we're being
reminded that every day
you